what's happened to la it it kind of
i i always thought of la and in even
california for sure
as kind of that hot blonde from high
school
that was always the bell the ball didn't
have to study very hard
phone rang every friday night for a date
really was able to kind of get by in her
looks and kind of cruise
and now that blonde is 47 years old
and not the bell of the ball anymore and
you know if you listen to gavin newsom
that guy i've heard interviews with him
going hey man where are you going to go
it's like it's like the 47 year old
blonde
saying to the the football star hey
don't you want some of this
and it's like no no i i can find
some of that's in texas or arizona or
nevada
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report joining me today is a
best-selling author
co-star of the wonderful documentary no
safe spaces
and host of the adam corolla show
podcast
adam carolla welcome back to the reuben
report
always good to be back dave all right
corolla we got a lot to do here because
this is my last interview of 2020
and we said who could we get on the show
to end the year
that is not completely bananas
and you were on the short list there
were only about two other people we
couldn't get them so
we got you you're on the shortlist of
dave rubin's sane people how does that
make you feel
you know when i write my next
autobiography
it's going to be titled from the short
bust
to the short list the adam corolla story
nice to be on the short list yes you you
have done it my friend all right first
off i got to ask you something because
there is a rumor going around town
my guys my team seem to believe this
rumor
that you're moving to texas now when i
talk about short lists
on my short list of la people i got adam
corolla
i got dennis prager i got larry elder
john voight that's it are you are you
leaving us
you're going to houston no not just yet
i did a hit on tucker carlson
uh i guess last week and they brought
the van
to my house and uh tucker
always does the when you leave in la and
i think he
he grew up in i think la and san diego
so a lot of the guys and him and shapiro
are the two when he leaving la guys
because they were in la and they
they left and i've always been in la so
just off the cuff because we're in this
van
that was a satellite van i just as an
im comedian i just said oh tucker as
soon as this hits over i'm gonna
commandeer this van
and i'm driving to houston and for some
reason
that didn't come across as a joke to a
lot of people but
you should have seen that it was a joke
people because i
if i was going to houston i would
certainly do it on a southwest flight i
don't think i'd commandeer you
you wouldn't want a 50 000 satellite van
wouldn't take the satellite van from fox
news and drive that all the way to texas
you do it first class on southwest i get
it
i feel like just from a mileage
standpoint
it would cost much more to take that
satellite van
all right so i'm glad to hear it sounds
like you're staying for a little bit but
i did have you over for dinner a couple
of months ago and you said you were on a
three-year plan
and we're watching cali just fall apart
i'm a native new yorker but i've been
here seven years you're you're from
socal man
what the high hell is going on here
yeah my kids are just getting into high
school if you want to call it getting
into high school because i
walked into both their bedrooms this
morning they're both laying in bed with
their covers over them and i went hey i
thought it was school time and
like we're on the zoom class from
underneath a comforter
um you know what's happened to la
it kind of i i always thought of
la and in even california for sure
as kind of that hot blonde from high
school
that was always the bell the ball didn't
have to study very hard
phone rang every friday night for a date
really was able to kind of get by in her
looks and kind of cruise
and now that blonde is 47 years old
and not the belle of the ball anymore
and you know if you listen to gavin
newsom
that guy i've heard interviews with him
going hey man where are you going to go
it's like it's like the 47 year old
blonde
saying to the the football star hey
don't you want some of this
and it's like no not i can find
some of that in texas or arizona or
nevada
or nashville tennessee or whatever but
there's a kind of a thing where it's
like when you're used to being the belle
of the ball
you don't study that hard you don't try
that hard i mean california
was always like we got the beaches we
got the mountains we got
all we got disneyland we got all this
great stuff so it's like well what about
how hospitable you are to business well
don't worry about that
we got malibu right and
what they didn't really factor on i mean
there's a few things
first off smart people don't want to
just hang out
and be essentially abused by their
government that's that's number one
number two there's a part of it that's
just practical like
i grew up out here my parents my mom had
a vw
squareback she had like a 70s vw station
wagon my dad drove a vw
bug forget about driving to arizona
we couldn't get to van nuys from north
hollywood without the thing
vapor locking and like i talked to a
friend of mine
uh dickie from the boss tones the lead
singer from the band the boss tones
and he was like yeah i moved arizona i'm
like oh so you got to go it's like i
the drive's not bad i got a great car
it's it's
it's got why you know it's it's got
serious xm and it's in a
uh heater in the seat and it's like it's
it's not that big of like physically
the transportation you know the the ten
flights a day that are
going from uh burbank to phoenix or jet
sweet x
you know like you can get to salt lake
city in uh 55 minutes like there's a
there's a kind of tangible mechanical
part of this
which is when i was a kid if you wanted
to move like
buying a ticket on an airline was a big
deal like packing up a rider truck again
physically didn't have cars that could
make it you know
it's it's all kind of doable now so so
what do you think
the future of this town is i think you
probably have a couple hollywood friends
that still talk to you i've got one or
two that would not be happy if i
mentioned their name
um but do you think that this town is
just now
condemned between garcetti at the at the
city level and newsom at the state level
do you think we are just truly condemned
and now gascon this new d.a
who's not going to arrest people for
prostitution or resisting arrest
or a series of other things like how
much worse can it get do you think
well maybe just a little bit and then
maybe it's time
like you know like a horrible alcoholic
maybe this
is the i've stolen my kids piggy bank
i'm gonna break it open to buy some malt
liquor
and i now catch a glance of myself in
the mirror
and i've hit rock bottom like maybe that
see you in the mirror thing maybe we're
there
i was thinking about gaston it's like
loitering is not going to be a problem
trespassing not going to be a problem
underage drinking is not going to be a
problem
prostitution's not going to be a problem
and i thought where the was this
guy when i was in high school
i couldn't really use this d.a when i
was in high school not only that you can
steal
up to 900 that's what they're telling
you so you could steal a playstation 5
and like seven games but you go into the
eight game range now you're in trouble
yeah it it it all seems like a very
eerie harbinger but
i here you you brought up hollywood like
our hollywood friends
um if you think about this
uh los angeles hollywood la
always been the sort of hub of
production right
and everything was filmed everything
every tv show
anyone ever saw around the world was
filmed in you know burbank
or culver city or somewhere in hollywood
i mean i've been on
all those all the i've been all the
stages i've been
all the lots i used to be at hollywood
center studios doing the man show
and we did crank anchors there i did
love line there
and at a certain point they started
getting greedy they started over
regulating they started over taxing
and so what did the most liberal people
on the planet do
they started drifting into atlanta they
started going to
canada started going to prague i mean
they literally just left
so it was called runaway production and
at some point
some semi-sober person thought we can't
just have
all of this money just physically
leaving the state
and they course corrected a little bit
they were like well why don't we offer
some incentives
for these businesses hollywood not to
leave the state
to do all as as i probably told your
audience
i drove from this studio
where i am sitting right now uh brian
cranston came in and did the show
brian's a good guy probably one of the
more liberal guys in hollywood
and uh he said like i gotta catch an
uber to burbank to the burbank airport
and i said i'll drive to the burbank
airport it's four miles away
so we jumped in my car and while we were
driving there he was explaining that
breaking bad was supposed to be filmed
out here
but of course they're going to new
mexico to film
and of course they lost all that money
and all the tourism dollars and all that
kind of stuff so
at some point they kind of wised up and
i said let's give some incentives
for these guys to stay and i gotta
believe
at some point they're going to try to do
that with business
you got to believe it and yet and yet
and yet we're in the lockdown capital of
the world i mean you're also one of the
the few guys i mean
you know i'm trying to do it too but
there aren't that many public people
in cali that are really publicly
fighting the lockdowns and trying to get
people back to work your whole
your whole sort of public existence is
sort of based around the value of work
and
and your story about work and you like
you like people that work
basically you see value in work what do
you what's your take on just
nobody's working i mean we got companies
with people working thankfully but
a lot of people aren't working you know
i think the
the problem it's it's it's kind of a
it's a
leftist democrat sort of mindset which
is
why do you work and the answer is to get
money
to buy food to take care of your family
to pay rent
okay well what if we just paid your rent
and gave you food
and it's like well that would seem to
handle the problem
mathematically at first glance but
you're forgetting about a super
important part of work
which is self-worth and pride and
self-esteem
and the depression that kicks in and all
that once you get on the dole so their
thing is
they have this bizarre approach to
reverse engineer
everything like hey if if a lot of young
black teens are being
suspended from schools then stop
suspending young black deets it's like
okay that's not going to fix anything if
if homelessness is illegal then don't
make it illegal anymore like this
and gaston is that way too it's like the
prisons are overcrowded
how do we fix that let everyone out of
prison
well that obviously doesn't fix you know
the
75 of the kids can't do uh math at grade
level well then
lower the test scores it's like okay
your car's not going fast enough well
then bust the glass of the speedometer
and take your finger and turn the needle
up to 80 miles an hour you're still
going 23 miles why is it though i think
i've asked you this
publicly on the show last time and i
know we've talked about it privately why
is it though that so many people cannot
make the jump from the stupid decisions
to their involvement in the stupid
decisions that no matter how many times
they vote in people and policies that
make everything worse like
right now if you and i walked out of our
studios and we just started talking to
people on the street
and you said to people how's it going in
l.a everybody would say
man it's a freaking mess or if you said
how's gavin newsom doing they'd all say
horrible no there's nobody defending
these people at the you know like
there's the rabid sort of crazies but
pretty much nobody else
but why is it and is it is it just
because of the weather it has fried all
of
our brains basically it's nice out so
people cannot
realize that the stupid easy answers
aren't the actual answers
i've been saying for a number of years
that all roads lead to narcissism
and for the people i know who vote that
way
they voted that way and they want to
kind of will themselves
to be correct because his ostensibly
what you're saying is
is you're a democrat yes
you vote democrat yes then you're
responsible for gavin newsom and
garcetti
yes well then you're wrong the next
thing you can say is you're wrong
you're wrong and these are people that
hate being wrong they have huge egos and
they never want to be wrong
so it's like a kind of a cognitive
dissonance it's kind of like
yeah i voted for that guy and yeah he's
doing a horrible job
but i'm gonna vote for that party again
because that way i'll never have to
admit i was wrong but you are wrong
because they're running the state into
the ocean the state has no money there's
homeless people everywhere
drug addicts our education's horrible do
you think maybe we should try voting for
somebody else
did you see when uh uh who was it um
bill maher had adam chiffon and mars
complaining mars going oh
all of my friends are leaving la because
of high taxes and blah blah blah
and shifts like oh well we're the
business friendly party and it's
meaningless what he's saying of course
but i wanted to kind of smack bill maher
through the tv and be like
what are you talking about you are the
one that's supporting all of these
people
and then all your friends leave and you
wonder why you're alone
well sometimes they don't even say we're
the party of they just go
well people are leaving because of over
regulation
and high taxes and a bad business
environment it's like
yes they're leaving because of all the
policies you enacted those are your
policies
that's why they're leaving yeah they
they seem to be unable to make that
that jump lockdowns i know you're not
happy you're as pissed as i am
you're tweeting about it all the time do
you think there's any
like on the science level do you just
think there's any science behind any of
this at this point there
i mean again right now we could both
walk out we live about 20 minutes away
from each other but we can walk outside
of our houses it's a beautiful day as it
always is
we cannot sit outside and have a coffee
because of lockdowns yeah
at a place where you purchase a coffee
yeah i think you could we could probably
go up to your roof deck
you're always welcome
actually i well you are welcome on my
roof deck but according to garcetti
you're not supposed to be on my roof
deck oh right
well a lot of it is you know most of it
is the crops are dying
we need a virgin to throw in the volcano
and
someone goes how's that going to help
the crops and they go you
shut up i got to do something the
villagers are upset
they want action i mean whoever that
the uh health minister or
czar whatever of los angeles as much as
admitted it's like i said
outdoor dining isn't dangerous we don't
have any data
to support it's dangerous but we want
people to stay home literally
you're not making that up that is what
the guy said yeah
well first things first do you get to
decide who stays home
that's your job your job is i will
decide
when you get to leave your house and
even if it's for spurious reasons and
there is no direct correlation between
any danger of spreading the disease and
eating outdoors
i'm still just going to make this random
decision and you shall stay home i mean
it's a very it's funny it's a it's a
comment that kind of
slid by a lot of people but it's it's a
very
scary precedent when the powers that be
are essentially saying you're gonna stay
home because i told you to stay home
and then you go give me proof why i
should stay home and they go
i don't have to give you proof i told
you stay home but
are you shocked how quickly we all
became sheep
i mean everybody everybody well
what what what i realized what has
happened
is california especially
los angeles especially it's so over
regulated it's so burdensome
it's so it's so tyrannical
and it's its leaders are so tyrannical
in terms of its burden
that they put on the taxpayers that we
all got sort of indoctrinated
into this slowly like imagine trying to
pull this off in 1955
right people just be like uh no i'm not
staying home
and by the way i'm by the way when i
leave my house i'm taking my gun
in case one of you tries to
arrest me like that's where we would be
at
but it was a slow quiet indoctrination
of i mean think about
what you can't do here's what you can't
do
here's what you must do here's all the
things you know
you you can't smoke in a restaurant okay
well go to the smoking
no smoking well then i'll go to the bar
no no smoking at the bar well then i'll
go to the patio no smoke in the bed
like it's such a crazy um
stockholm syndrome that everyone lives
everyone who lives in california has a
kind of a stockholm
syndrome like i would say i say all the
time hey
your business your restaurant there's no
reason why you need to shut down your
outdoor dining
you've made a lot of concessions you
spent a lot of money just eff these guys
stay open and everyone's like
i don't want to get into trouble well
that's what the over-regulation has
created
this this this huge sort of umbrella
always you know under the guise of
safety
and everyone is just scared but but
slowly scared like
just think about think about
you know what think about the beach i
always talk about the beach but think
about the beach
like imagine telling someone from the
50s
in malibu hey you can't have that
cigarette on the beach
what are you doing i'm drinking a beer
you can't drink a beer on the beach
i mean you look at the sign i always
tell everyone look at the sign
at the beach uh in the 50s they didn't
have a sign
at some point it was like no bonfires
between
3 a.m and 6 a.m you know i mean now it's
like no frisbee
no dogs no football no cigarettes
no literally no humans no humans like
literally yeah no humans on the beach i
mean think about what
think about how they ratchet it up think
about how the sign gets longer
they always add something to the sign
they never remove something from the
beach sign every year there's two more
things you can't do
on the beach and when you go physically
look at those signs now
it is a a scroll of things
citizens can't do on our beat
so what do you think that is as a
as a student of the human mind as i
consider you
what do you think that thing is when you
say they meaning
they always make the list longer i mean
when you say they you in essence you
mean us
right like what what is wrong with us
i'm starting to come around
to that that there is just something
wrong with the collective
us that's why i don't like collectives
that we are just
going to not only do this to ourselves
but we're going to pat ourselves on the
back as we do it
well as our friend dennis prager always
says you know we
we mistakenly think people yearn to be
free but they really yearn to be taken
care of
they would trade freedom for security
any day of the week
so if you yearn to be taken care of then
you want more of this government
and if you yearn to be free you want
less of this government and the freedom
thing
it's kind of it's like when we try to
liberate some middle eastern nation like
come on they want to be free
no they don't they don't want to be free
they want to be led
oh god we got we got freaking work to do
man we've got real work to do so what
what would you do if if corolla i've
been you know promoting this
corolla for governor thing because i
jokingly said it on fox or on something
and now i was in dc last week
and literally everybody was asking me
when i'm running for governor
i'd much rather have adam carolla do it
uh but what would you do if you if you
were governor if you were mayor like
you open us up are we are we open
tomorrow
i would say let let's
follow the science as as they say if if
it seems
first things first show me all the
countries
show me all the states show me all the
cities that lock down
hard and then i want to find out what
happened
four months later like where were they
locked down hard
and now they're having a huge spike what
what
what are the difference between you know
sweden and florida and new york and
california
like first things first i want to know
what locking down
even does it does nothing i know i mean
i think we know that at this point like
california we live in a state where
we've been in perpetual lockdown right
some level of serious lockdown and you
know this everywhere you go
people are wearing masks so we've been
doing that since march eight nine months
already
florida's open so shouldn't florida have
at least
double the numbers as us triple the
numbers exponentially higher but
no they don't so like isn't you know
not a scientist and and they have
uh the second most uh
elderly people well the first numbers
but the second percentage of
elderly people as well so first things
first
if this isn't doing it if locking down
isn't doing it then we're not going to
lock down
that's number one number two as far as
like
businesses go you want to go to a hair
salon go to a hair salon if you don't
feel safe going to a hair salon then
don't go to the hair salon
if you don't feel safe going inside a
restaurant then don't go
we're not making people go out to dinner
for those who may be compromised or
maybe
living with an elderly person or
whatever that is
i like when this whole goddamn thing
started it was presumed that everyone
lived with their grandmother
you know it's like according to cnn 87
percent of americans
lived with a 90 year old like i would
always go let my kids just go back to
school and they go
whoa whoa whoa and i'd go there it
doesn't affect the kids
they don't oh yeah but what about that
gaggle
of super old people that are in your
house
that we were unaware of before the
pandemic and it's like i don't know how
many people
in california live with their elderly
parents and if in fact you are
a loser and you live with your elderly
parents
then you should make the decision not to
go to the salon
but i know you mean that some good
people live with their elderly parents
because they're taking care of them
no nobody it's it's all to get the
inheritance basically
yes all right let's talk about the
election a little bit i'm just giving
you like the whole landscape of all the
craziness of the world the election
where are you at at this point
apparently joe biden is the
president-elect
i i don't think uh you voted for joe
biden did you
did you officially announce who you
voted for i know where where you're at
politically but did you actually say it
on your show no but
i would definitely vote for trump over
over biden yeah
um the the
the interesting take on it which isn't
you know
insanely impressive in terms of the math
but uh
sort of what ben shapiro has always been
talking about for the last several weeks
which is it's not that the election
was rigged per se by
the states or the vote counters or
mail-in ballots it's that it was
essentially rigged by
cnn los angeles times new york times
most all legacy and mainstream media and
then big tech and you know all the
googles and the
and twitter and all that all that it was
rigged by them
essentially and if you really think
about it it's not much hyperbole
i mean if you think about just the
hunter biden story
as an example and you go okay and forget
it's hunter biden and forget what the
allegations are and forget anything
let's just be generic
there's a story it's a credible story
and it would hurt one candidate
and i don't know if that means three
points or seven points or i don't know
what it would translate into but it
would definitely be
damaging to one of the candidates so in
our
in our hypothetical world there's a
candidate and b
candidate and b candidate would
definitely be hurt by a story
that comes out several days before
the big election and then
all the legacy news organizations and
then
and then silicon valley they all
conspire
to crush a story and are saying things
like russian disinformation or there's
no proof whatsoever
so that story never comes out well
i would argue that that is tampering
with the election it's certainly
affecting the election i mean i guess if
you say
what's the definition of tampering with
an election
i guess the definition would be
affecting the election
one way or the other for this candidate
or that candidate so
they're all on board to do this
they always do this thing it's funny
when the smartest people in the world
the silicon valley guys go
oh yeah we didn't know what was going on
with that thing we
we made a mistake we're gonna get better
processes we should have looked at that
before
right you didn't know huh and and
by the way it's pretty simple uh they
found a laptop had a bunch of
information on it
might you have some follow-up questions
or you just announced that's russian
disinformation so
you had a whole group of people
when i say a group i mean most 90
of the media essentially running
interference
for one of the candidates and and all
the way through just you know the covet
vaccines never going to come out before
the end of the year etc
on every single story uh yeah that's
going to translate into a few points
and that is that is the tampering do you
think there's
anything left at this point in terms of
mainstream media
like i think if if my one takeaway
probably of the year
beyond lockdowns and the way we give up
freedoms and all that but like my one
sort of tangible takeaway is that there
is
simply nothing left in mainstream media
that doesn't mean that a hundred percent
of reporters are all artists
but i think the way they treated the
hunter
by it and story then the way we were
immediately told not to look at anything
related
to election fraud and if we did we're
we're basically alex jones and
everything else
like to me there's nothing left you know
washington post
new york times cnn like it's just done
am i am i over the top
well there's something left but the
question is
is what did they do to their brand
so if you think about think about
what the oscars means in 2021
versus the oscars from our childhood it
was
first off it was appointment viewing get
the whole family
see who the best picture of the year who
got the and the best picture of the year
got
that was the best picture of the year
you know i mean we didn't argue about it
and we didn't think there was any
politics involved and it just
was you know and by the way you know
when you look at the
ratings for these shows you realize it
ain't
what it used to be by by the long shot
and and i'll give you a couple examples
so think about
the oscars think about the emmys think
think about how i did a little
experiment around here
i have young people who work for me i
said uh if you heard a story out of cnn
five years ago
what would you have thought and they
went i would have believed it and i'd
say
what do you think now and they go i'd
have to go look into it so
cnn new york times all the entities you
mentioned
but also oscars emmys
maybe the nba uh rotten tomatoes yeah
you know you see hillbilly elegy oh it's
with the critics but 88 with the people
oh what a shocker you know
no safe spaces is i don't know 44
with the critics and 90 with the people
so so no we no longer have to go to we
don't have to find out what the critics
have to say
on uh rotten tomatoes because it's
skewed
everything is skewed and whoever wins
the oscars gonna be
you know oh he's he's the black gay teen
who's struggling with the sexual i was
like
okay i get it and and by the way when
you do that
you are shaking hands with the devil you
really are in terms of your brand
the oscars should have never let all
this super woke in
because it was once you announce
we now need 50 people of color
nominated for the best actor it's over
it's over we stop
we stop we go were they the best actors
or is they just
meeting a quota by the way so they're
shooting themselves in the foot
but the best part of it is they decided
to put all these quotas in about you
know skin color and sexuality
and you know if you're a or you
have a lazy eye or whatever except they
said we're not going to do it for three
years
it's so important to solve racism and
sexism but
we still have some stuff in the can so
we got to get that racist crap out of
the way
and we'll do it we'll do it in three
years uh you mentioned no safe spaces so
i'm sure most of my audience has seen it
already but when when you think back to
the project
because you guys probably you and dennis
and the team probably started working on
this thing what like
four years ago maybe something like that
yeah when you think back to the project
i mean it basically everything and i'm
not just saying it because because we
both happen to be in it but everything
that no safe spaces is about
which in essence is that all of this
woke craziness
from the college campus is going to leak
into re into real society
it's what everyone sees now and we were
all told we were racists and bigots and
the rest of it for talking about it
are are you kind of are you like
impressed that we kind of called it or
are you depressed that we kind of called
it or
just is what it is because we called it
we all called it now
everyone knows that that is the the
stuff that is happening everywhere right
now
well first off how could it not like
what if
what if your kid leaves for college
and then every one of their professors
is a vegan
and then they're teaching classes on
meet his murder
don't tell your chef husband because he
makes a
delectable wagyu i think we have it by
the way
did i hear correctly on your podcast i
think the day or a day or two after
you came over here for dinner i think
you said it was the best steak you ever
had
it was man so so kudos to you
for uh living with that yeah i handled
the steak you see
i i was doing this oh damn you're right
i didn't you're right you were there
when i was flipping it man
i had a couple of scotches at that point
sorry dave you get all credit to dave
rubin for doing
doing the steak but um what the hell
were you talking about now i forgot
about it
that you send if you send your kids to
these schools they're being taught by oh
yeah
okay so everyone's a vegan and meat is
murder
uh how long before your kid starts
coming home for thanksgiving and saying
no thanks to the turkey because meat is
murder and then
when those kids in their vegan
environment get pushed out
into main street and madison avenue
and start showing up at corporations how
long before
they start judging people for eating a
ham sandwich
and how could it go any other way of
course it's going to go that way
i mean you get you go to this place
where a bunch of ideology is taught to
you
and then th the construct or
or at least college is basically there
to i mean if you think about
what what is the what what is the
mission statement for
college well you go to this place for
four years
we teach you a bunch of stuff and then
you take that with you
into society right well we just thought
it was going to be a bunch of
engineering and calculus and
you know art history we didn't know it
was going to be an indoctrination to a
bunch of ideas
but it is and i would argue those ideas
are more powerful than
engineering are because you can't just
walk into your
new job at kinko's and start talking to
everyone about structural engineering or
shear loads or tension anchors or
something they're not gonna
it's not gonna take but if you start
talking to everyone about your ideology
then it's going to spread and that's
exactly where we're living
so how do you make sure your kids
they're not college age yet
uh but how do you make sure that they're
not getting infected with this stuff
because from everyone that i know that's
a parent in this town
even if they're going to the most elite
private school people that are even in
religious private schools i'm talking
catholic schools
orthodox jewish schools like the vocism
has now infected
virtually everything how do you make
sure that stuff
doesn't get through to your kids well i
don't give a i'll be in houston by
the time this
to college remember the plan uh
you know the i don't think
see i don't think you should wrestle
with them
over ideas um it's going to have an
effect
my son is um very conservative
he's a dave rubin fan he's a dennis
prager fan
he's a ben shapiro fan he he loves all
that stuff
i didn't have to wrestle with him over
ideas my daughter's very progressive
the reason my daughter's very
progressive is because she wants to be
liked
and my son doesn't really care he's just
a doofus dude
but my daughter wants to be popular
you know and if you want to be popular
you better be down with black lives
matter
my feeling with kids is you shouldn't
really get preachy with them
but you definitely need to lead by
example like you just go
here's what i do like almost every time
i go to work
i just go i'm going to work today
because that's what i do and
i would do things like when i would go
out on a friday night to the comedy
store
and do a set i would go to my son i
would go to my daughter and i'd go okay
it's eight o'clock and i'm going to from
la canada to uh hollywood the sunset
strip
and i'm gonna go there and i'll be back
at 11
and i'm not getting paid i'm doing this
for free i'm doing this to get better at
what i do
that's what i'm doing and i would leave
and i just would imprint in them
that there's no shortcuts it's hard work
lead by example
and you know i don't know that you're
you're going to be able to talk them
i don't think you can talk them out of
anything you can
show them who you are and how you live
is that is that tough for your daughter
uh
because you are you like your daughter's
friends must know who you are you talk
about this stuff has has that been an
issue
no my daughter i was just out uh took
her and her friends out driving the
other the other night
um they understand who i am on a sort of
human level they understand i'm a good
guy they understand like a fun dad and i
provide a lot of stuff and
we get to do lots of fun stuff because
of me and
you know i'm sure if we ever sat down
and really got into political
conversation would end in a huge
argument as my son and my daughter
frequently do
but um no i think it's important
and and i feel this way about
relationships
that i've had in hollywood uh they need
to know who you are they need to know
that you're a good person
that you're family oriented that you pay
your taxes like
they need to understand because we all
know it's just a big smear campaign
right
racist sexist whether you disagree with
someone on the left and it's because
you're homophobic or xenophobic or
whatever misogynistic uh it's
hard it's really harder when they have
to argue with a human being
you know when when when the conceit is
that's a good person
he loves his family and he's a good
citizen
and now we're just left with what we
agree and disagree
on you know so i think you can sort of
have that with your kids like i really
feel like they need to resp
you can't tell them don't smoke while
you're smoking
you know what i mean you have to kind of
lead by example
and that's kind of my approach so
it's kind of tying that to the to the
political part of it i mean we don't
have much of that
we're being told right now if you listen
to the the media and the body and thing
like now is the time for us to come
together
no more of the meanness i'm a president
for everybody
all that stuff it strikes me as very
fake because
all of these people the media all the
the democrats basically the
establishment if trump
had won and by the way i'm still not
convinced this thing is over but
which i'd love to hear your thoughts on
as well but if it was reversed if trump
had just won on november 3rd
they'd all be screaming burn it all down
but now there's sort of this fake like
oh
let's kind of be friend's thing do you
think there's any authenticity there
any any or even any value to it it
doesn't seem valuable to me
like oh you got what you want you're the
child who got the cookie
so now we can be friends again but if it
had gone the other way
no no no no i do think there's way too
much
and a lot of it was just a way to attack
trump
it's like he sets the tempo for the
country
you know like people rely you know like
it's like
when you know it's like he told everyone
to inject
bleach into their veins people listen to
him like who injected bleach
who drank bleach i know a couple people
i wish i'd drank bleach but nobody
actually did it who did all these things
like well when he says things you have
to understand that so many people is
like ah
i don't know do we really take our sort
of cues
from a etiquette standpoint from the
president
i think the conceit so what's going on
now
is they created
the left created so much chaos around
trump and so now their thing was like
don't you just want it to end
don't you just want to chaos in so it's
almost like somebody broke into your
house
let five macaw parrots go inside
and then was yelling at you don't you
want this to end and you're like
i do but why did you break into my house
and let five macaw
parrots lose and they go you want it to
end right i want it to end it's like
okay but you're the one who let the
parrots out
and then at some point the the second
part of the narrative has to be
well now that that's over let's preach
unity but
it's it's never gonna manifest itself in
any real way and
it already hasn't and i think it's all
lip service
so do you think we're irreparably broken
right now like i don't know anyone
truly i don't think i know anyone that
supported trump that
fully thinks that this thing was legit
and if that's the case regardless of
who's sworn in on the on the 20th i mean
we've got
like a seriously broken system
even even me like my faith in the system
is seriously broken right now which
makes it hard in a way to
to be someone that communicates ideas
the way that we do
because i'm trying to be honest with my
audience and my faith in the things that
we talk about
is is shaken
well i think in terms of how it
manifests itself
and maybe this just sounds um you know
self-congratulatory or something but if
you take a look
at the physical manifestation
of of unrest you know and you take a
look at
antifa and black lives matters and all
that kind of stuff
they're out in the street they're
lighting stuff on fire they're looting
they're
they're accosting elderly couples that
are eating outside and
drinking their wine and dumping it on
their head and everything
that's basically how they act when they
don't get their way
the right and the conservatives don't
act that way when they don't get their
way they're probably
equally as unhappy about it but it
doesn't really manifest
and all the are like well what
about the clan or
what about the proud ones okay there's
ten of them like
when's the last time you saw the clan
take over a city and have the cops stand
down
and burn everything down and loot
everything i think i think i watched the
time to kill i think that was what it
was i think in 1993
and there was a movie about 40 years
before that yeah
right okay so i think
that the conservatives who you know by
nature are just more
they're more conservative they're not as
impulsive you know they're not going to
go out and start burning things
i think they're going to be unhappy
they're going to feel like they got job
in this last election
they're probably going to sit back and
laugh a little as
the democrats start with the infighting
and the aoc
side of it starts getting into it with
the biden side of it
and they're going to watch him kind of
crash and burn
and then it's going to be real easy to
get a dan crenshaw
type in again or you know there's a host
of
you know strong candidates on the right
and it'll just set the table
to repeat what just happened four years
ago
do you think it's kind of funny that
maybe 15 years ago when you were doing
love lines and doing
uh the man show and everything else that
you
you would end up talking about politics
as much as you do i know you talk about
everything but like
everything is now politics in a weird
way do you think it's kind of odd
you know i never really think about it i
always wanted to kind of
do something a little different than i
did the year before and kind of evolve a
little bit
um also there's an interesting
phenomenon
which is when people say
you've changed you know to me you know
i say to him name me one
thing that i've changed my mind on since
i was on love line
25 years ago you name me one thing if
you'd asked me
about border security i would have been
for it if you'd asked me about gay
marriage i would have been for it
if you would have asked me about you
know decriminalizing pot i would have
been for it
if you would ask me about voter id i
would have been for it
i would have would be asking me about
lowering taxes i would have been
born and raised the worst episode of
love lines i ever heard
it's super boring for the 14 year olds
but i have not
changed my opinion on anything that's
the way
but it wasn't considered political then
you weren't considered political
now everything gets pushed through this
sort of prism
of of politics i i still don't look at
myself as
uh political i look at myself giving my
opinions
like when you go should you present an
id
when you vote i go well do you need an
id to buy a pack of cigarettes or to get
on an airplane yes okay then you need an
id to vote
okay so you're this political person
right and it's like no
that's just my opinion on that but on
the other side of the aisle
i'm all for gay marriage and i don't
feel that's political either i don't
even feel like it's
i i know it gets seen through the prism
of something political i don't feel it's
political i feel like you're asking me
should we have a strong border and i go
yes
and that's that's where i'm at that's
all right with everything
if that just means you're racist not
political right that's right
all right let's talk about something
really political then because how many
books have you written is it is it four
i feel like it's probably it's five
you've written five books and as far as
i know according to my research here
three of your books have made the new
york times bestseller list
but your last book adam corolla did not
make it
but we know that the new york times
bestseller list
is a crock of yes how does it make
you feel to not make a list that we know
i mean
i know you know the the internal numbers
you obviously probably should have been
number two or something the week that
you came out
does that stuff bother you anymore or do
you just like it is what it is
yeah i'm kind of it is what it is it's
it's kind of weird when you see
that you outsold a bunch of books that
are on the list and when you look at the
title
of the book you know all something to do
with race
all something to do with gender all
something that whatever
um then you understand and
it's a little frustrating momentarily
because you go oh we should be on the
new york times bestseller list but you
also
in a a good example of somebody's
diluted their brand
they've they've they've compromised
their brand new york times bestseller
list
oscars rotten tomatoes you know
it they've diluted it they're they're
hurting their brand
it doesn't if i now hear a book as on
the new york times bestseller list or
more importantly
didn't make it on the new york times
bestsellers i got questions
i never would have had questions 15
years ago would have been well that one
book sold more than the other book
that would have been it zero questions
now
i have questions and and that's what
they've done and i don't think they
know the kind of long-term damage that
they're doing to their brand again
new york times best sellers that's a
huge brand oscars huge brand
but if it was a stock you would see the
arrow heading down
over the last 10 years you know it was
funny when
when my book was coming out in april and
everybody kept you know all the
publishers agents every oh we're getting
we want to get you on the new york times
bestsellers relying on the new york
times
and i kept saying everybody but you're
all telling me it's fixed that the whole
thing's fixed
what you want to get on it you want to
get on the fixed list and it's like
we're all we're all running for
something that kind of doesn't exist
in a weird way and i thought well if
that if they if they
mess with their with their lists that
should be about just
sales right a sale you know the top list
it's like well it kind of tells you what
they're doing on the editorial pages as
well
or on the news pages as well oh for sure
and uh again you know the part
the only part that frustrates me
and you know you're talking to a guy
who's made a bunch of movies that were
very well received and none of them
have gotten into sundance none of them
and the you know again if you look at
the people on rotten tomatoes you'll see
a hundred percent
95 percent very good doc
i mean i have three of these docs on
netflix
right now netflix bought all three of
these documentaries
certainly good enough to make the cut at
sundance
none of them will get have gotten into
sundance and nor shall
any doc i ever make get into sundance
and the part that frustrates me whether
it be
getting into sundance or the new york
times bestseller list
is that people don't know what's going
on
the people general societies like well
if you didn't get into sundays make a
better film next time
you don't get it there is no sundance
for me there is no new york times
bestseller list for me there is
none of that for me that they shall ne
it's never going to happen
and you guys think it's about the
quality of the product
i can hear my audience screaming so
corolla why don't you conservatives
build different institutions why isn't
there the corolla film festival
why isn't there the la canada film
festival
well there's gonna be and you know
parlor and places like that i mean
it's it's going to happen i mean if you
take a look
you know it's funny about two years ago
if you looked at the itunes charts
1 through 50 there was no conservative
shows
podcasts on there maybe shapiro
but i mean really nothing else you go
look now there's 10.
they created that they they actually the
mainstream media
and all these places where they're the
best thing that ever happened to dan
bongino
right or carly kirk or whomever right
they created their business
through trying to suppress all these
ideas
and so there there will be a new new
york times bestsellers or a new
you know sundance or whatever or the
whole thing will just be antiquated and
no one will care anymore
like who cares if you've gotten to this
film festival or not is the film good or
not and where can i find it
right it'll probably be can you adam
corolla get to your audience somehow and
if you get your stuff to enough of your
audience then
that's probably good enough that's
probably it so as we enter
the final stages the final last few days
of this 2020
and we roll into christmas what else is
on your mind
at the moment like what else are you
thinking about that you know not not
this
sort of day-to-day stuff that we're
talking about in the political and it's
like what else has just been
sort of interesting to you lately
i've been really kind of drilling down
and and speaking to dr
drew quite frequently about people's
reaction
to this pandemic and what colossal
cowards so many people have turned into
and why why why so fertile
why is this soil so fertile for these
cowards and what's really going on
and something i've really been thinking
about is
risk and then risk assessment
and i started to think about
all the guys i work with and i work with
a lot of guys
restoring cars and building
houses doing so half my life is creative
and the other half is kind of
blue collar and i noticed that the blue
collar guys were always very
even they're not worried about it as a
matter of fact i don't think i've ever
discussed
covid with any of the guys in my shop
they're literally not interested
they just get up and go to work and then
i started thinking about
their relationship with risk is
is very finely tuned because
if you're going to fire up a lathe and
put a
ingot of aluminum on it you got to start
taking a
sharp knife to it uh chisel to it or
something you better
have your relationship figured out with
danger
and also what what things
so when you work construction you work
carpentry you have to pick up a tool and
the tool's got a blade on
it and you got to use it but you have to
use it in such a way
where you're safe but you still have to
get the job done and so there's a
constant
calibration going on like because you're
going to lose a finger
or you're going to lose an arm or you're
going to lose your life if you don't
really
get this relationship worked out with
danger
so i don't think loggers are
nearly as scared of covid as
guys who do data entry because when you
then
get into this air conditioned cubicle
you
no longer have to assess risk you don't
have you know if you're a window washer
or
roofer or whatever like if you do what
we used to do when
when a huge percentage of society would
go to a factory
or go to the sawmill or go to the lumber
yard or do whatever it is
these sort of blue-collar tangible
hands-on jobs
it's constant risk assessment it's just
can this scaffolding hold me because i'm
going up to the third floor it's just
it's a constant and you're not aware of
it it's just your brain is constantly
wearing it so when you see
covid those guys have assessed the risk
and it's minimal all the people that are
sitting around watching cnn
all day on a zoom call are not
calibrated
so they're all they're all inflated and
the more of our society
that kind of gets off the construction
site and gets on you know think about
think about when you work on a farm
every second is some sort of risk
assessment right all the equipment
you're dealing with and whatnot
the more of our society that moves into
the digital world
the more difficulty we're going to have
assessing risk
and that's what we're living right now
then on that note bring us home
with some hopeful stuff for 21 for 20
21 21 i was going to say for 20 20 give
me something for 2121 do we still exist
or give me something for 2021 anyone
listening
you cannot just uh reside
in the digital world you will go insane
you will lose your bearings you must
get something tangible in your life i
don't care if it's gardening
i don't care if it's crocheting get down
to the garage and start a project
put a patio put a pergola on your home
you have a beautiful pergola in the back
your home dave go out there
physically get your hands dirty if
you're just gonna go down the
i'm gonna watch cnn and order grubhub
all day you will go insane
and you see it all over the place you
see these middle-aged people like
spazzing out on other people who aren't
wearing a mask
walking alone on a horse trail they
can't assess
risk it's the death of math you need to
put yourself
in some vulnerable positions if
something scares you a little bit
you got to go do it go go out white
water rafting or something you have to
get
outside you have to get in a tangible
world
and you have to have projects and by the
way once you have a project like a
tangible project then you're in
problem-solving mode your brain is
occupied you're not thinking about
global warming you're not thinking
you're trying to solve problems on a
micro level not a macro level
trying to solve world hunger or systemic
racism
or global warming you will slowly go
insane because you can
there's no finish line you'll never
solve it
you'll just be preoccupied preoccupied
with it
corolla all i had to do was loft it up
you took care of the rest merry
christmas my friend
i'm i'm glad you're at least temporarily
staying in la
and because then i thought oh god am i
gonna have to move to houston and it's
so humid
and you know the hair would be so flat
there you know you've got that nice
curly hair it doesn't really matter
but for me it would just yeah but
i guess for you it would do this yes i'd
go out like the hair bear bunch
if uh you're planning on uh you know
broiling some more meat
uh definitely uh shoot me a tax man
because i will be there
there will be meat and by the way you
mentioned my rooftop before we just put
up
four three foot by four foot planters so
we're doing a little gardening
so i'm i'm living the the corolla
lifestyle
up up over here and actually i do have a
couple stucco things i need you to fix
so i'll text
after this i'll bring my sponge trowel
all right see adam thanks dave if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell